what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder I'm Warren Thompson
and today we have some absolutely insane
details about the Avengers King Dynasty
and Avengers Secret Wars it looks like
we know what Marvel studios's plans are
for these two movies how they're going
to execute them and now we've actually
learned how some of these other movies
like Deadpool 3 are going to directly
lead into Avengers Secret Wars we knew
that was going to happen but it seems
like now we know the exact way that it's
going to happen and we have a
confirmation about Kang Dynasty that
we've been talking about for a while and
we assumed was going to happen and that
is The Avengers are going to lose
they're going to lose to King but not
just one king it was already teased that
there's a council of kings and that
there are literally infinite amount of
variant of Kang we learned that in Loki
season 1 and Loki season 2 is right
around the corner it comes out this week
and although we don't know how that ends
yet this new report does give us some
insight about how that will connect also
stay tuned tomorrow we announce our
giveaway winner for the month of
September and of course we're starting a
new one for October if you want a chance
to win an Xbox series X A PS5 some
Marvel Legends items or some DC items
all you have to do to enter is subscribe
and leave comments on our videos the
winner picks one item and we pick one
winner at the end of each month also I
have seen Loki season 2 episodes 1
through 4 I'll be doing a reaction to
them tonight so stay tuned and tomorrow
morning I'll be doing a spoiler-free
review so subscribe and hit that
notification Bell to be alerted for
those two videos coming out so today's
report is coming from The Insider my
time to shine hello she has an excellent
track record with Scoops she is a
trusted source and today she has posted
kind of a very brief summary of both
Avengers King Dynasty and Avengers
Secret Wars so obviously we'll first
start off with King Dynasty where she
states King Dynasty 616 Avengers team
fight the Council of kings and lose now
like I mentioned this is something that
we assumed was going to happen we pretty
much knew it was going to happen The
Avengers are going to lose in King
Dynasty and that's going to directly
lead into Avengers Secret Wars now how
Secret Wars picks up is really cool and
she talks about that but let's first
address what was said about King Dynasty
with the Council of Kings now there are
two ways to look at the Council of Kings
one way is to Simply look at it as every
Kang variant that was there in the post
credit scene for Ant-Man on the WASP
Quantum Mania they were there as the
Council of Kings the entire population
of kangs that meet with each other are
the Council of Kings that's one way to
look at it however I don't think that's
what my time to shine hello is referring
to because in a huge movie you need to
have a main villain you need to have
main villain to focus on it can't just
be everyone for the sake of the entire
multiversal Saga yes the villain can be
the many different variance of King the
Conqueror but for one specific Avenger
film they need to fight one villain or
three since we are dealing with a
multiversal threat and they do have
variants it makes sense for there to be
a few villains even for one Avengers
team to fight because that signifies the
threat and it shows us that it's not
just one king but it's indeed many kings
however there are kings that are in
charge of others and that is the Council
of Kings which is the king Trio ramut am
mortis and the Scarlet Centurion and
since these are the leaders of all of
the Kings we're assuming they're going
to be super powerful so we've assumed
that the Avengers are going to lose to
them much like they lost to Thanos
originally in Avengers Infinity war and
then of course they came back and one in
Avengers endgame well it won't be too
different here in King Dynasty they'll
lose but then in Avengers Secret Wars
they're going to come back and try to
win in a way that some fans might not
have expected but I have to say I'm
really loving this idea for the second
part of this report from my time to
shine hello she States Secret Wars the
TVA sends a team of multiversal Avengers
they have secretly recruited led by Toby
Maguire Spider-Man Hugh Jackman's
Wolverine and Ryan reynolds's Deadpool
to save the 616 Avengers and defeat the
Kings once and for all now this sounds
absolutely epic a Secret multiversal
Avengers team led by Toby Maguire
Spider-Man Hugh Jackman's Wolverine and
Deadpool hell yeah sign me up for that
now we've been hearing about Toby
Maguire's Spider-Man and Hugh Jackman's
Wolverine teaming up for a pretty long
time now actually probably over a year
now however I think a lot of us just
thought that an Avengers Secret Wars
there was going to be a scene where a
bunch of different variants from a bunch
of different universes come together and
fight together and that's when we were
going to see Toby Maguire Spider-Man and
Hugh Jackman's Wolverine come together
kind of like an Avengers end-game portal
scene except for portals it's simply
universes colliding and other Heroes
coming together now I'm sure we're going
to still be getting something like that
since the incursions are happening and
this is about the multiversal war
However the fact that there is a Secret
Avengers team out there in a multiversal
Avengers team out there led by Toby
Maguire Spider-Man and Hugh Jackman's
Wolverine with Ryan reynolds's Deadpool
well that's amazing and I am super
curious to see who else is going to be
on this Secret Avengers team and how
they come into play in the earth 616
universe as well as the other universes
as well now this makes us even more
excited for Deadpool 3 because we know
that Deadpool 3 is when all of this is
going to really start to go down we know
that we are going to see many variants
in Deadpool 3 and it looks like This
Could Be Where The Avengers team comes
together we know the TVA is going to be
involved in Deadpool 3 in a pretty big
way we know Owen Wilson's Mobius is
going to be in Deadpool 3 and based off
of everything that we've heard we know
that the TVA is actually going to be
saving superheroes from universes that
are experiencing incursions basically
the Multiverse is starting to collapse
in Deadpool 3 well really it's starting
to collapse now it's basically been
collapsing since the finale of Loki but
the TVA is still going to play a part
and trying trying to save the Multiverse
so we're not sure of the exact details
but we know that in Deadpool 3 they are
going to essentially be doing a Noah's
Arc for the Multiverse meaning they are
going to be saving heroes from a bunch
of different universes and putting them
all in one Universe saving them from
their dying universes but putting them
all together for a chance to save the
entire Multiverse the Noah's Arc report
Came From Grace Randolph and the battle
World Report meaning the TVA is going to
take a bunch of Heroes and put them on
one world or a battle world is coming
from insiders like Daniel rpk so we
don't exactly know who is going to be a
part of this new multiversal Avengers
team and we don't know who the TVA is
going to specifically save however
according to this report from my time to
shine alow we know who the leaders are
going to be now of course we know Ryan
Reynolds is Deadpool and Hugh Jackman's
Wolverine they're the stars of Deadpool
3 and we have heard reports for a while
now that Toby Maguire would be returning
as Spider-Man and even that he would be
working alongside Hugh Jackman's
Wolverine and now we know know why they
are apparently going to be leading the
multiversal Avengers team and this makes
perfect sense we've actually been
theorizing about this for a while it
makes sense for the Multiverse to have
one team it makes sense for Secret Wars
but even after Secret Wars it makes
sense to have a multiversal team to
monitor the entire Multiverse to make
sure a huge war or a huge multiversal
threat like Kang doesn't burst out or
get out of control now as far as who the
rest of this multiversal Avengers team
could be literally anything is possible
Doctor Strange could be a part of the
new team it would make sense to have
somebody from our universe be a part of
it Loki could actually be a key player
since Loki season 2 is about to happen
you could have extremely powerful
mutants like Professor Xavier come back
and we could have characters that
haven't been introduced in the fox
universe or the Marvel Cinematic
Universe yet completely new characters
or some old characters played by new
actors literally anything is possible
and that's what makes Deadpool 3 the
King Dynasty in secret War so exciting
and right now just the entire future of
the Marvel Cinematic Universe is getting
really really and more and more exciting
but go ahead and let us know your
thoughts about these reports in the
comments down below what do you think do
you like this idea are you stoked for it
or not don't forget to give the video a
like And subscribe so you don't miss out
on any of the latest videos you can find
us on Instagram and Twitter as well and
as always thank you all so much for
watching woof
woof